STEVE THAIR: We started off
with the offline panel.
Now we're moving into a
networked world, where we are
connected to a network even
though obviously we discussed
a lot of network connected stuff
in the earlier session.
I'm going to introduce the
panel very quickly.
From the end, we have Ilya
Grigorik from Google.
If any of you have been to
Velocity have seen Ilya
present, he's going to give us
a little opening talk for 10
minutes just to set the scene.
So he shares an office with
Steve Souders, I think.
There you go.
Next to him, we have Andy
Davies, who's a local boy.
So we're from Bristol.
I don't know, where are you
from originally, Andy?
ANDY DAVIES: Wales.
I'm Welsh.
STEVE THAIR: [INAUDIBLE].
He's from Wales.
Occasionally, they win a rugby
game but not lately.
Next to him, we have John
Cleveley from the BBC.
He was responsible for migrating
BBC News to a
dynamic platform, been building
features mobile
first, using responsive design
all the way up to the desktop.
Yeah, I think Andrew wrote
that piece of thing.
And last but not least,
we have Jackson.
And Jackson's presented at our
London web performance user
group and Velocity, and
stuff like that.
He's described here as a
veteran troublemaker at
Facebook London.
I think it's supposed to be
troubleshooter at
Facebook London.
No?
Troublemaker?
OK.
Works on tools and mobile, help
build mobile Timeline and
App Center.
Saying you had anything
to do with Timeline
is extremely brave.
Cool.
So basically, we're just going
to kick off with Ilya giving
some opening remarks.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I'm not sure if
this microphone is working.
No?
Yes?
STEVE THAIR: That one's not.
Just use the [INAUDIBLE].
ILYA GRIGORIK: This one works.
That works.
Now what's the magic trick
to get this thing?
There.
STEVE THAIR: We wave
to the nice man.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
Hello.
Waiting, waiting, waiting.
Warming up.
STEVE THAIR: Tell a joke.
ILYA GRIGORIK: All right.
Well, no jokes here.
It's all serious stuff.
It's all network performance.
JACKSON GABBARD: The
crowd looks lovely.
You look great today.
ILYA GRIGORIK: But seriously,
I'm not
going to take 10 minutes.
It's far more interesting to
talk about on the panel to
answer-- there's a lot
of questions in the
Moderator as well.
So I'm just going to kick
off with a couple of--
let me see, wrong screen.
That is weird.
Can you guys see that?
All right.
There we go.
So one thing that I've
discovered as I've been
working on network performance
stuff is, I've been becoming
grumpier and grumpier, in the
sense that people keep asking,
hey, we should put more
stuff on pages.
I want to put more images,
more video.
I'm like, no, no, don't do
that, because that hurts
performance.
Everything you do hurts
So the fewer things you put
on your page, the better.
So because of that, I've started
actually migrating my
HTML presentations to Bash just
to illustrate the point
that go as low level
as you can.
So this is actually running in
Chrome VSSH but in Bash.
So it's awesome.
Anyway, moving on.
So a lot of the network stuff
is not the sexy stuff.
We can talk about all the
awesome things that we're
building, all the new
CSS animations.
And then you start talking about
performance and it's
like, yeah, that TCP thing.
Ugh.
So a few things, I have like
four high-level things that I
want to seed the discussion
a little bit.
Cache primitives.
So we heard a lot about
caching and offline.
And I'm really excited for the
stuff that's happening in the
offline panel.
I think that's a big,
big improvement.
It'll obviously take some
time to get there.
The local storage stuff
is really interesting.
I'll just add maybe one more
comment to the earlier
discussion.
I don't think it's
a solved problem.
The fact that it's a sync or
async API I think, is maybe
slightly the wrong question to
ask, because for example, if
you look at local storage
performance on Windows, it's
actually really good.
Why is that?
Because they have SuperFetch,
which is a platform feature
within Windows which pre-loads
all the data
independent of the app.
So this is not an IE feature.
IE doesn't have these latency
delays that Chrome does.
In fact, Chrome is
like the worst
performer in local storage.
It's something that
we've got to fix.
So I don't think it's as
simple as we maybe
make it out to be.
Just having an async
API doesn't
necessarily solve the problems.
I think there's an 80% solution
even for something
like local storage.
The fact that this new
controller script is actually
interacting with the browser's
cache, I think is awesome.
Unlike the previous versions,
which it's
either all or nothing.
You don't have a fallback.
So I think this is
all great stuff.
But moving on, something that
I've been spending a lot of
time thinking about
and fighting with
is user-agent sniffing.
I think we can all agree that
this thing is just dead.
We all have to use it.
It's unfortunate.
It sucks.
You have to pay for
these databases.
You have to get a new
serving path.
It is a disaster, no matter
which way you look at it.
And not only that, but it
doesn't actually give you the
answers that you're looking
for, which is the best
combination of all
those things.
So I do have a proposal
out there.
We actually have a prototype
that's in progress in Chrome
for this thing called Client
Hints, which is the world's
dumbest idea, which is if you're
looking for a DPI, why
don't we just send it to you
in an HTTP request header?
That's really all it
boils down to.
So if you're curious,
take a look.
I'd love to get your feedback.
But I think this would actually
help quite a bit with
a lot of problems in the
responsive design world.
And speaking of responsive
design, if you talk about
network performance and web
pages, 60% of all the bytes
that we ship today are images,
which is huge.
So if nothing else, if there's
one area we can really focus
on and fix and improve, it seems
like images would be it.
And unfortunately, if you look
at what's happened in the
image space, nothing
has happened.
We have PNG, JPEG, and
GIF, and that's it.
And it's not obvious why we
don't have another 10 formats.
I don't know if 10 is needed,
but at least another couple.
We have WebP that we have
proposed at Google.
And WebP gives you a lot
of improvements.
But I don't think WebP
is the end all.
I'd hope to see more
image formats.
And it's not obvious why we're
just stuck with these three.
Then you look at products like
Opera Turbo, Silk, PageSpeed.
Opera Turbo is an incredibly
popular browser in a lot of
countries where bandwidth
is at a premium.
Like 90% of all of the
improvements that all these
proxies get is they
just re-encode all
the images with WebP.
That's literally all they do,
just blindly transcode
everything to WebP.
So that alone is like, why don't
we do that for the rest
of all the pages?
So we could decrease the size
of our pages by 50% by just
re-encoding all the images,
which seems like
a pretty nice thing.
And speaking of re-encoding
images, one
thing that I've realized--
I've done a lot of studies now
looking at WordPress sites and
a whole number of
other content--
it turns out we, as humans, suck
at picking image formats.
We are either lazy.
We are either too busy.
We pick the wrong formats.
So we save things as PNGs,
which should be JPEGs.
We save things as JPEGs,
which should be PNGs.
It's just a disaster.
And there's a lot of image
optimization solutions out
there that exist that you
actually can pay for, which
will say, hey, we'll optimize
your images.
If you give us a PNG,
we'll strip the
metadata and all the rest.
It's like, cool.
You're going to strip
100 bytes out of my
150 kilobyte image.
I'm like, that's still a win.
But the truth is, you should
have been saving that as a
JPEG, which would have
been a 15k file.
And we're not doing
that transcoding,
because it's much harder.
I think that's something
that we need to fix.
And this problem only gets much,
much harder when you
look at the responsive area,
where now you have different
break points.
You have different
device widths.
I recently ran a study looking
at how frequently do we
re-scale images on a client or
downscale images on a client.
And it turns out that about 20%
of all the large images
are getting downscaled
in the client.
So we're shipping extra bytes,
which was getting compressed.
This is just wasted bandwidth.
I think we need server help.
We need a client-side
solution, which
we don't have today.
There's a lot of room for better
server integration to
help us with this problem,
because it only gets worse.
You have five different
viewports.
You have high DPI, non-high DPI,
now you have 10 variants.
Add some art direction use
cases, and now you're like,
you started with an image tag,
which was beautiful, one line.
Then you look at your picture
tag, and it's like 40 lines.
And you're like, I am
not writing that.
I'm sorry.
At least that's for me.
Another crowd favorite--
net info API.
So let me just talk about
this one for a second.
So bandwidth estimation--
should we have bandwidth
estimation in a browser?
And the answer is no--
ever.
Yes.
Right.
So why is that?
It's worth actually
thinking about it.
And usually there's
a good counter
argument to that as well.
We have that.
We have that for video.
And the insight there is when we
do do server adaptation for
video, but the way that works
is we stream you a five
[? to ?] second chunk
of video.
Then we see how you
downloaded it.
And then we adjust.
So it's adaptive streaming,
not predictive streaming.
If you look at the actual
bandwidth throughput,
especially on mobile, your
mobile carrier can adjust your
bandwidth on one millisecond
granularity.
Me moving a phone from here on
my desk to here can double or
take my bandwidth by half.
There's such high amounts of
variability that we can
predict bandwidth, or we have
stable bandwidth on the order
of milliseconds--
maybe at most, second.
It's completely unpredictable,
anything beyond that.
So you sending a request for a
GIF file and then fetching
that and saying, ooh, one
megabyte per second.
And then making a decision
is completely useless.
So maybe if we switch all of our
internet back to circuit
switch networks, then we can
have this conversation.
But I don't think that's
going to happen.
And then the last one, which I
think is something that we
haven't actually talked about,
is radio and mobile.
So mobile is obviously a big,
big topic for networking.
And battery life is something
that I don't think we, as web
developers, have actually
thought about at all.
Battery life is actually, turns
out, very important for
native apps, because people
rank these apps.
You run this thing, and your
battery's dead, and you're
like, this app sucks.
For web pages, we haven't
thought about it.
But in reality, they
are just as costly.
I can point you to pages where
if you sit there reading your
news, for example, on some
sites which are using
real-time analytics, every
five seconds they send a
real-time beacon for a real-time
analytics app.
You're just draining
your battery.
It's killing your battery.
The radio is the second most
expensive thing you have in
your phone in terms of power.
The first one is the screen.
The second one is the radio.
And they're actually
about the same--
the same order of magnitude.
So turning off your radio
is incredibly important.
There is big, big anti-patterns,
stuff like
inefficiency of periodic
transfers.
And I think this one's really
illustrative, because even if
you look at the Android docs,
two years ago when we started
building these native apps, we
said, hey, fetch just the
stuff that you need.
And then as the user needs it,
fetch the rest of the content,
thinking that you don't
have enough bandwidth.
And you should get the best
experience up and then
progressively fill in.
If you look at the docs
now, they tell you
completely the opposite.
They tell you download
everything.
Burst everything you can
as fast as you can.
And then turn off the radio.
And please, please, please don't
turn it on ever again.
So I don't think that message
has reached the
web developer community.
And it's actually pretty
interesting to think, I don't
think we have an answer for
how exactly do we service
battery and network
performance?
What's that trade off?
We don't have an intuition in
the browser for what is the
cost of a page.
I'd love to see a metric that's
says, you've drained x
amount of your battery by
visiting this page.
That would be kind of cool.
And then the last one is
4G won't save you.
I see a lot of conversations
about this, which is like, I
heard LTE is going to
fix all things.
I'm just going to
wait for that.
Seems reasonable.
And it seems reasonable
when you're here.
You're in downtown London, then
you probably have really
good coverage.
The problem is when you actually
look at what the
carriers are saying, they're
saying, look, we've invested a
lot of money into 3G
and 2G networks.
We have a lot of users on older
hardware that can't
migrate to 4G overnight.
3G and 2G networks will continue
to exist for at least
another decade, at least
another decade.
And you'll have to build apps
that will transition between
4G, 3G, and 2G.
And that's just the
reality of it.
You can't design your apps
just targeting 4G.
So those are the high-level
points.
That's all I got.
I think we'll go
into the panel.
STEVE THAIR: I think
we're done here.
That's pretty good.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE THAIR: I'm going to try
to come out from behind the
panel a bit so I can actually
see them instead
of talking to them.
Make sure you talk to them.
Don't talk to me.
Can everybody hear
me all right?
Yeah?
OK.
So the first question we
actually have-- the highest
ranked question on the list--
is, should we have continuous
live feedback access to the
user's network speed, similar
to [? navigate ?]
[? or battery? ?]
And the answer is?
ALL: No.
STEVE THAIR: You'd think
we rehearsed that.
Awesome.
There are actually a
few questions that
were about that topic.
Some people obviously
hadn't heard of net
API, some people had.
I don't even think it was worth
really asking any of
those other questions.
Just say no?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Can we take
a step back, though?
STEVE THAIR: OK.
ILYA GRIGORIK: We can't have
bandwidth estimation.
I can't tell you you have two
megabytes per second, three
megabytes per second.
It is useful to know which type
of network you are on,
which is the level of
granularity that you should be
working at.
Knowing that you're on Wi-Fi
tells you certain things
about, for example, the latency
characteristics of
your connection.
You're now going to have a weird
transition state where
you have to wait for two seconds
before you actually
get any packets on the wire.
If you're on 4G, you
have pretty tight
bounds on latency again.
Knowing on 3G-- so basically
it gives you goal posts.
Like, here's what the minimum,
here's what the maximum is.
And that's about the level
that we need to operate.
So the net info spec
actually had this--
the earlier versions.
It specifically said,
Wi-Fi 2G, 3G, 4G.
I think we need to revert to
spec, like, 15 iterations, go
back and implement that.
JOHN CLEVELEY: Also, when I'm
at home in Suffolk in the
middle of the country, my
Wi-Fi I get about a meg.
I come into London with my
phone and I get about the
same, even better sometimes.
So it's like you've got to use
the information quite wisely
in terms of not making
too many assumptions.
But the latency thing is
definitely going to help make
decisions between 3G
wireless and Wi-Fi.
JACKSON GABBARD: It's always the
one-legged dog [INAUDIBLE]
from the 4G, you get
intermittent one-bar
connection.
That's not as good as
the 3G connection.
But yeah, even then it's
still fraught.
[INAUDIBLE], it's not granular,
immediately useful data.
ANDY DAVIES: The original spec
got dumped for privacy
reasons, didn't it?
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think
the privacy reason
is completely bogus.
So let's just put
that to rest.
AUDIENCE: One other factor,
could it tell you that the
[INAUDIBLE] is roaming,
moving?
AUDIENCE: Use the mic, please.
STEVE THAIR: So the question
from Daryl was, could the spec
just at least tell you whether
the person is actually moving,
like if you're in a moving car
and a moving train, which has
an impact, certainly
on 3G, anyway.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I guess you could
enable GPS and look at
the coordinates if
they're changing.
But hold on, but I think there's
two different things--
roaming and moving are
two different things.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STEVE THAIR: Yes.
He meant motion, as opposed
to paying 25 US dollars a
megabyte through Verizon in
Gibraltar type roaming.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
STEVE THAIR: That would probably
also be useful.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I don't
think that's a
concern of net info.
So if you are on the move, for
example, 4G performance is
much, much better than 3G
performance if you are moving.
I don't think that's something
that net info would service.
STEVE THAIR: So one question
from me is that if net info is
giving you an API that you
have to query in your
JavaScript, and then you send
that message back, why is the
browser not sending that message
to the server side in
a header or an unsolicited
cookie?
So from the point of view before
I've even served the
request, I've got an idea of
what the connection type is.
ANDY DAVIES: Well, that comes as
part of Ilya's Client Hints
spec, which is also growing into
the same privacy concerns
from some people.
So the idea that whenever
somebody makes a request of
your server, you expose their
screen size or how they
connected, starts to give
you ways of actually
fingerprinting browsers.
And we can do it pretty
well anyway.
So there are some privacy
concerns about it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So, once
again, privacy stuff--
completely bogus.
Because you just
look at your--
no, no
STEVE THAIR: Who do you
work for again?
ILYA GRIGORIK: If you have the
IP address of your visitor,
you can do reverse map to say,
hey, you're on T-Mobile.
And you're coming from the
subnet, so you're probably on
3G network.
That is what the CDNs
are doing today.
This is all the information
that we're exposing.
So I think this actually
doesn't hold
much water, this argument.
AUDIENCE: I actually don't think
the privacy issue has
been the main killing issue
of these features.
That with the sending in
additional headers, the
problem is, there are billions
of requests happening every
day right now, right?
If you add even, like, 20
bytes of data into each
request, we're talking about
gigabytes and gigabytes of
data being sent for absolutely
no reason in 99.999% of cases.
So that's the main problem
about [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Mic, please.
JACKSON GABBARD: I
agree with that.
I think the crux of the issue is
less the network connection
of [INAUDIBLE]
the information that you can
glean about the network or the
device that you're sending to.
That's the thing that-- when
you're trying to get the
biggest ones you can--
network request--
knowing what the device
can handle ahead of
time is pretty key.
And I think sending each
request is not
necessarily the right way.
But it goes back to what you
said before about user-agent
sniffing, like knowing
concretely on the server side
what to send.
It's also a really, really
hard problem.
But I feel like that's the
trick, like that's the magic
bullet in a lot of cases to
get good [INAUDIBLE].
These are the things I know
I don't need to send down.
And in the immediate [? query ?]
world, you send it
off with the layout, send it
off with the JavaScript.
In reality, you don't
need to do that.
Like a [INAUDIBLE] device, you
just don't need to send stuff.
And in some cases, you
don't even have
JavaScript on the devices.
You definitely don't need
JavaScript resources.
But there's no sure-fire way.
I'm curious, though about
user-agent sniffing.
Because I know what we do.
I'm curious what other
folks do for that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Everybody
does it.
You have to.
STEVE THAIR: But you don't
like to talk about it.
AUDIENCE: I have one.
About--
AUDIENCE: Could you introduce
yourself quickly?
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yes, thanks.
You introduced me,
but thank you.
Yes, I had a comment about the
spec and about the previous
version of the spec.
I think there was an argument
about privacy.
But another thing was that many
people were claiming that
the type of network is really
not enough information.
It's not telling you enough
about the type of connection.
You might be in a conference
like this on a Wi-Fi that is
complete cluttered, and you
don't get any throughput.
Or you might be actually on--
STEVE THAIR: Or in a
[INAUDIBLE] station
any day of the week.
You'll have five bars of signal,
and you're on a 3G
network, and it's completely
digested [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And the problem that
we have with the net info is
that we're trying to find a way
to get this information
without defeating the purpose,
like the [INAUDIBLE]
problem, or measuring
bandwidth.
It changes so quickly, and you
have to measure so often that
you're going to be draining
the battery.
You're going to be defeating
the purpose entirely.
So that's a very hard
problem to solve.
I would be happy to go back
to the connection type.
There are many different use
cases, and we have to see
which ones are more important.
ILYA GRIGORIK: [INAUDIBLE]
some sort of notion of a
connection quality.
I don't know how to
define it exactly.
But it's kind of that losing
your Wi-Fi signal, you have
just enough to be connected
but not enough
to do anything else.
That is a good example.
Or you'd keep timing out.
But that needs to be
serviced by the
operating system somehow.
I don't think the browser should
be the one trying to
claim this one.
AUDIENCE: I work on a browser.
I work occasionally on
Chrome for Android.
And we've been talking a lot
about this particular issue
and this particular API.
And the thing we've come to
understand, as it relates to
the last session, is--
AUDIENCE: Step up to
the mic, guys.
AUDIENCE: The thing we've come
to understand here is that the
only meaningful data point is
the point at which you're
actually requesting
a resource.
That is the only time when you
can make any sort of a
decision that's worth a damn
about whether or not you've
got good quality, because
anything else is opening up a
window, which your expectations
might be violated in.
So if I go and I ping
occasionally to a server, now
I've got a window in which I'm
going to make assumptions
about the quality of
the connection.
And I'm likely to be
unfortunately shocked and
surprised by the terrible
things that
happened in the interim.
Tying this to an actual request,
I think, is the only
way to do it.
And we don't have any other API
right now that does that.
JACKSON GABBARD: I don't
even know if that's
really the crux of it.
I feel like the answer is
just to think about your
application from the standpoint
of minimizing your
risky network time and also
taking as many steps as you
can to harden your application
against it--
so not putting all your eggs in
one chunked HTTP request.
Bring it up over multiple HTTP
connections when necessary.
[INAUDIBLE] the steps to me,
arguing about whether or not
we should or shouldn't detect
network connectivity state is
like arguing about whether or
not the sky should be bright
colored blue.
We're not going to know.
It's not going to be good
enough information.
So what are the things that we
do that are reasonable to make
the application decent
in spite of that?
That's the part of this
discussion that I find
interesting.
STEVE THAIR: Can I actually--
I was going to say, John, you've
got a practical example
with the BBC apps.
What are you guys doing?
And do you care?
And how are you dealing
with that issue?
JOHN CLEVELEY: Yeah, we care a
lot about making sure that our
site works really well on low
bandwidth, because we have a
lot our users use the
World Service sites.
So we basically are always
really anal about file size,
looking at HTTP requests.
And going back to working out
what connection you're on, I'm
interested in what people
actually will use it for.
You can imagine users going to
the site on broadband and then
going on 4G on the phone and
getting completely different
user experience.
I'm interested in what
differences are we going to
actually be able to do if you've
been detected at a
higher bandwidth?
And [INAUDIBLE] you got video
and images of the big things.
We've kind of been really
efficient with
our file sizes, basically.
And as you said before, images
is the big thing.
So even though we haven't got
responsive images as any sort
of standard, basically, we're
using JavaScript to work out
what's the container size.
And then we've got a number
of recipes on the server
producing a number of different
image sizes.
And we grab an appropriate
image for
that particular device.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Do you do
that in real time?
How do you generate
the different
versions of the images?
JOHN CLEVELEY: Yeah, they're
generated the first time then
cached on server, and
then onto CDN.
JACKSON GABBARD: In the
generated case, I'm sure you
got multiple resolutions.
Do you require the people who
are publishing the stories to
upload to separate
resolutions?
Or do you--
JOHN CLEVELEY: No.
So they'll create one raw
image, because they're
journalists.
[INAUDIBLE] are actually
users with Facebook.
So that might be a little
bit different.
So we make sure the journalists
are uploading the
biggest size we can.
And then we've got 20, say,
different image sizes that we
would select from.
STEVE THAIR: So you transcode
all of that effectively server
side for the--
JOHN CLEVELEY: Exactly.
We resize it.
STEVE THAIR: Selected process
that's doing that re-scanning.
JOHN CLEVELEY: Exactly.
It's just a URL that we hit, and
it will do it on run time.
ANDY DAVIES: Do you do any of
the art direction stuff?
JOHN CLEVELEY: Sorry?
ANDY DAVIES: Do you do any
of the art direction
transformations on the image?
Or do you just crop them?
JOHN CLEVELEY: No, it's
literally just re-sized.
STEVE THAIR: We got a
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Somebody said that the
connection quality would
have to come from
the [? RS, ?]
but I think it can come
from the browser.
One thing we do when we're
monitoring a website is keep a
track on the time to first
byte for each host we're
talking to.
And if we see that go up, we
fire off a network test.
So the browser itself could
track and say, hey, this is my
average time to first byte
from Facebook.com.
And you can respond to that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: But your time
to first byte in mobile
networks will vary dramatically,
because you have
different radio state
transitions.
So for example, on 3G, you
can be anywhere from 200
milliseconds to two seconds.
Just because your rating--
AUDIENCE: You can ask it
to give you standard
deviation or min/max?
ILYA GRIGORIK: No, no.
But this is just your
first packet.
This is your first packet.
After that, you're
pretty good.
It's 100 milliseconds
or less--
50 milliseconds.
AUDIENCE: You keep
measuring it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ILYA GRIGORIK: No, but the
point is then you wait.
Then you wait five seconds.
And then you will once again
incur two seconds.
I think the fundamental problem
that we have, is we
have this mental model of
Wi-Fi networks or mobile
networks being the same as
wired networks, which is
fundamentally wrong.
And because of that, we feel
like there's all this
variability, all of this
randomness, all this latency.
But once we actually understand
why these delays
are there and you design for
them, hey, I know I'm on 3G
network right now.
Every once in a while, I'm going
to dispatch a request
which will first block for
up to two seconds.
And this may not be a problem if
it's just like a background
update thing, because
who cares.
But if this is an interactive
user clicking on something and
you're on 3G, that's a UX
pattern that you should be
aware of, because you probably
need a different feedback loop
in your app to say, hey, this
could take a while.
JOHN CLEVELEY: So you're saying
you'd have a different
user experience depending
on what sort of
network you're on?
ILYA GRIGORIK: I'm just saying
you should design
with this in mind.
If you're on 3G, if you're on 4G
even, some actions, like if
my phone has been idle for a
while, the first network
interaction that you're going
to have will have a delay--
anywhere from 100 milliseconds
to two seconds--
before any packets
get dispatched.
JOHN CLEVELEY: So going from a
mobile first approach, do you
think we should use that
behavior as the standard for
everybody in terms
of making sure?
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's probably
a reasonable thing to do.
AUDIENCE: Just one comment,
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm basically my own firm.
Just one comment regarding the
measurement of time to first
byte, would resource timing,
especially if we could add
byte size into resource timing,
we could measure
continuously the end-to-end
bandwidth
throughout the download.
It's extremely complicated to
measure the bandwidth between
the various resources, but we
can have a fuller picture of
the download.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Great, we're
going to have a
fuller wrong picture.
STEVE THAIR: I'm going to move
on from this topic, because I
think we've done it to death.
You either believe that
measuring the bandwidth is
useful for you, or you may
believe that measuring the
bandwidth is a complete and
utter waste of time.
I think it really comes down to
if you're more for John's
point question really is, why do
you want to know, and what
are you going to do with
that information?
You're not going to be switching
between four
different viewport things of
this application or ways of
displaying this application
on a millisecond basis.
Who really cares?
One quick point?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE],
Mozilla.
I heard this fallacy about if
the viewport is big enough,
then we [INAUDIBLE]
bigger picture.
That actually says that if
the screen is bigger, my
connection is faster, which
is not really true.
So [INAUDIBLE]
Retina displays and these kinds
of things, I can't be on
a slow connection with my
Retina display machine.
I still don't want the two-meg
background image.
So the question is, in Flash,
we had adaptive
streaming of videos.
And why don't we get this
in the HTML5 world?
What do you we need to do to get
this [INAUDIBLE], because
right now one can start using
Flash for that kind of stuff.
JACKSON GABBARD: [INAUDIBLE]
I guess for me--
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the essence of the
comment with mics?
JACKSON GABBARD: I don't
know if I can or not.
It's complicated.
So the essence was, device
screen size is no proxy for
network activity.
That's the measure that we take
against what [INAUDIBLE]
and what switches
we send across.
You mentioned the Flash
[INAUDIBLE]
where you can get
a [INAUDIBLE].
You need something along these
lines for the HTML
[INAUDIBLE].
Basically, you get the lower
quality image with low
bandwidth case naturally
by [INAUDIBLE]
that we don't have currently.
Is that the essence?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JACKSON GABBARD: I forgot what
I was going to say about it.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE THAIR: And the
answer is, yes.
We need that.
Very good.
So I want to get on.
There are some other questions
on other topics that I want to
cover and get away
from net API.
So one of the questions which
you started to talk about with
you had different visions and
[? optimized ?] stuff, there's
a couple of questions in here
that are basically around
should I be compressing?
Should I be using
minification?
What things should I be
doing during my build
cycle in order to--
does minification really save
you all that much when it's
going to be gzip compressed
anyway?
JACKSON GABBARD: I have
a poll question here.
How many people here--
STEVE THAIR: How many
people here--
JACKSON GABBARD: How many
people here have a build
script for the they work on?
STEVE THAIR: Have a build
script for the
project they work on?
JACKSON GABBARD: Holy shit.
Wow.
STEVE THAIR: That's like
pretty much everybody.
Awesome.
JACKSON GABBARD: Nice.
I had no idea.
This is awesome.
STEVE THAIR: And how many of
those build scripts include
performance optimizations?
Now you're just showing off.
That was about everybody
again.
So who's doing minification?
Who's doing image optimization
and resize on the fly?
Oh, about a tenth of the
people who answered the
previous question.
What else would you
like to see?
JACKSON GABBARD: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE THAIR: This is a question
for the panel.
What else can people do in their
build cycle that you
think is really going to help
their delivery, particular
over high latency, low
bandwidth networks?
JOHN CLEVELEY: I think the other
thing you can do is, for
JavaScript, you can't power
everything into an all.js.
You do get to the point where
it starts to get massive.
And so if there are other pages
where actually it's a
specific bit of [INAUDIBLE]
that you can have in a different
package, then
sometimes it's good to work
out what you can spit out.
So the majority of
pages, you're
still using this all.js.
But on these other ones that you
can get away with spitting
things out.
So we use AMD to do that
kind of stuff.
And there's probably all sorts
of different dependency type
things that you can use.
So it's not always about making
one massive file.
Sometimes you need to be a
little bit clever about how
you split stuff up,
bundle stuff.
JACKSON GABBARD: Thank
you for that.
So the approach that we take for
Facebook is that there's
two levels.
There's basically all
the important
interactions that matter--
clicking on links, loading
things by XHR.
And then there's all the rich
features, all the really
bulky, all that JS stuff.
And so in the header page,
before the body, with all the
[INAUDIBLE], we'll send out all
of the basics, the really
tight, "do not put bytes in
here, you're wasting human
lifetime" sort of stuff
in that [INAUDIBLE]
JavaScript.
And then the stuff you need
later, you'll get to it.
Eventually you'll get those
features, and then the
widgets, the flyouts, the
[? beepers on the site, ?]
the core interactions that are
JavaScript enhanced, they'll
be there immediately.
It's the exact same approach.
JOHN CLEVELEY: And it's just
downloading what the user's
actually going to use as well
and using feature detection.
So if you're doing video,
check that the user can
actually play video before you
download your HTML5 player and
things like that.
So just looking after the guys
with the bad phones, because
they're probably got bad
JavaScript as well and
probably are on slow
connections--
I'm making lots of
assumptions here.
But you generally
get the idea.
Basically it's just progressive
enhancement.
That's the most basic level.
ANDY DAVIES: But there also a
lot of people who are afraid
of-- particularly in the
design community-- of
server-side stuff.
If you look at media queries,
the showcase site for
responsive designs, and you look
at the configuration of
some of these guys' servers,
there's basic things like,
gzip compression missing,
keepalives missing, cache
directives missing.
There's a lot of basic stuff
that as a web industry, we're
really bad at doing.
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's actually
surprising.
Maybe not in this room.
I think in this room, most of us
here have the basics right.
Turns out most of the rest of
the industry still has the
basics wrong.
That's a big problem.
STEVE THAIR: I'm
an ops manager.
I'm going to disagree
with that.
Just because all the developers
in this room are
doing everything right sure as
heck doesn't mean the ops guys
who run the servers
are doing it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: All right.
Fair enough.
So we talked about JavaScript.
I'll come back to images.
60% of the bytes--
images.
You probably have your PNG
optim, jpegtran or something
built into your build script.
Chances are, you're still
missing the opportunity to
transcode it to a better
image format.
I'm guessing half of your PNGs
are bed encoded as JPEGs and
vice versa.
This is a much harder problem to
solve, because it's likely
that your PNG is hardcoded into
your app, which means you
need to rewrite your code.
But this is a huge, huge
opportunity that you should
look at today.
And you guys have a server-side
solution to do the
image resizing.
I think this is something that
more and more people need to
deploy, because we just stick
images into a markup and
resize them on a client.
And that's a big problem.
JACKSON GABBARD: The hard
problem, it's sort of an
exponential nature, because if
you want to serve every single
resolution, well, that's
a different image size.
If you want a full width image
for every single resolution,
that's a massive number
of resolutions.
And so the coping mechanism we
use is to basically put it in
four-ish categories.
I think we have roughly
four sizes--
very, very small, original
iPhone, high-end iPhone world,
and then gigantic, tablet-y,
very high-resolution Android
phone-y stuff.
And then use careful CSS to let
it crop on the client in a
way that's reasonable.
And that way, you never quite
get exactly the right thing in
all cases, but you end up having
to have not a mess, but
not a server side storage.
AUDIENCE: Yeah this is
[INAUDIBLE] from Mozilla.
One thing we saw when we were
looking into doing WebP was
that the reason it wasn't
commencing was we saw that
people could just use better
JPEG compressors.
When you're encoding to JPEG,
if you just use better
parameters to your JPEG
compressor, you can actually
win about the same order of
magnitude as this 30% that
WebP currently proposed.
It's quite possible that WebP
can do even better.
But the order, the wins that
people were shooting for could
be had in many cases with just
passing better parameters to
your compressor.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think
there's a couple
of threads in there.
You have quality level.
And most of the time today, we
save our JPEGs either as 100,
or if you're advanced, you'll
save it as an 85.
We can go way down into the
tail and actually get very
good visual performance at
a fraction of the cost.
WebP does have about 30%, on
average, better compression at
the same quality level, the
same perceptual level.
It is definitely the case that
you can take all your JPEGs,
save at a lower quality,
basically re-compress them,
and get much better bytes
on the [? wire. ?]
So that is definitely true.
And I think that's an
under-appreciated area
generally today.
JOHN CLEVELEY: One thing as well
is, if you want to work
it out from a UX perspective,
how many images you need to
show [INAUDIBLE].
You can fool around with
compression, but actually if
you get to the desktop
BBC News site, we've
got a lot of images.
And so that's something we're
looking at to work on.
In our mobile site,
we've only got 10.
And that's just a massive win.
And so it's working out just
trying to do less but do the
stuff you do do really well.
I think that that's the biggest
thing for network stuff.
STEVE THAIR: On the feature
phone, you drop the images
altogether on the news
page, don't you?
JOHN CLEVELEY: Yeah
that's right.
So if you hit our site on a
feature phone, like a Nokia,
you'd literally just get
the first image.
And that gets replaced out with
a better quality image if
you're on a wider screen.
And then we post-load all the
other images with JavaScript.
STEVE THAIR: We've got
a question from Colt.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, quick
question--
Colt McAnlis from Google.
So can we actually talk about
how the fact that the smaller
image compression formats we
have decreases our network hit
and actually increases
our runtime hit.
So all those JPEGs and PNGs have
to be decoded to a full
resolution 32-bit and then
transferred to the GPU, which
actually puts more pressure on
the GPU memory, causing more
invalidations and actually
hurts your runtime
performance.
What are our thoughts
on fixing this?
ILYA GRIGORIK: I don't think
there's a fix for it.
It's a trade-off.
How does WebP give you better
image compression?
Well, we have more advanced
algorithms that
take more CPU time.
And vice versa, you need
more time to decode it.
So this is an interesting
trade-off.
It will take more time to decode
a WebP image than it
does to decode a JPEG image.
And you need to look at, maybe
if you were building a game
and it's like you have a ton
of image [INAUDIBLE], maybe
your CPU, especially on
a ARM processor, is
your limiting factor.
Maybe be at that point, you
make a decision to use
something else.
We recently did some studies--
I don't think we've published
anything yet at this point,
but I think we will.
We looked at Image Search at
Google, where we moved
everything to WebP and just
looked at, what are the wins,
what are the losses?
We do take more time
in the CPU.
We take a lot less time
on the network.
Then that trade-off is we're
still better off using WebP in
that specific case.
And this is your Image Search
page, which has like 20 or 30
images at different
resolutions.
So this is, I think,
a great point.
It's something you need
to keep in mind.
STEVE THAIR: OK.
The I think we've done
images to death.
We've got about 10
minutes left.
I want to try to move on to two
semi-related topics that
are very network specific.
The first is some guy named Andy
Davies from Bristol asked
the question, with the adoption
of multiplexed
protocols like SPDY and HTTP2
and the prioritization of
resource downloads by the
browser based upon the type,
will data URIs become
an anti-pattern?
That's one question.
And then there was another
question that was basically
about web sockets and
stuff like that.
So I just want to move on
to talking about those.
So does anybody want
to answer Andy's
question other than Andy?
Or you can answer your own
question if you want to, Andy.
JACKSON GABBARD: I think it
echoes what you said earlier--
the idea that the best request
is no request.
So [INAUDIBLE]
is pretty sweet for that.
It's all there.
If you're [INAUDIBLE] mobile
app, you can put all your data
URLs into your CSS and you
have one CSS file.
That's a win.
I can't imagine a world where
going from no request to any
request isn't a better
trade-off.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Why do
we inline stuff?
It's because we have limitations
in HTTP 1.1, which
make small requests expense.
It's the same reason
we sprite images.
we concatenate
files, all of this stuff.
With SPDY and HTTP2, that goes
away, because we can multiplex
all the stuff in parallel.
You can send all of your
requests at the same time.
We don't need multiple
parallel connections.
Yada, yada, yada.
Then coming back to inlining,
inlining is a
form of a server push.
Here's the idea.
In HTTP2, we have this proposal
to say, sometimes the
server actually knows what
you're going to request before
you request it.
Like I'm sending you
the damn page.
I know the resources on it.
So why don't I just send
you the resources?
Seems kind of obvious, right?
So that's the idea behind
server push.
And inlining is push, because
you're saying, look, I know
you're going to ask
for this icon.
So here, page 64 in the file.
Forget it.
Don't make the request.
That's a trade-off
of HTTP 1.1.
With 2, we can actually get away
from that and say, by the
way, here's the file.
And why is that a win?
So let's say you have to have a
small icon or a big icon or
whatnot, and you inline
into a page.
Now you're inlining that thing
into every single page.
It fits on multiple pages.
So you're just bloating
the size of each page.
Whereas with push, it can
actually be in your cache.
So I think it is mostly
an anti-pattern.
I'm sure there's one or two
use cases where there may
still-- like, if it's only
used on one page, it's
effectively the same.
STEVE THAIR: There's another
question here which is about
web sockets.
It seems that abstractions like
Socket.IO and Pusher are
the preferred way to
use web sockets.
Is this a failing in the
specification process?
Is it now the expectation that
new DOM APIs will be needed to
be wrapped by libraries
or frameworks?
So basically saying, does the
specification suck so bad
you've got to use another layer
on top to make it work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE THAIR: We'll take
that as a no.
So, apart from the guy from
Pusher in the audience, who's
using web sockets, and are they
using web sockets in a
mobile device?
Can I see a quick
show of hands?
So that's about four,
five people maybe.
Does anybody have any really bad
problems in a mobile world
that they think that causes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE THAIR: One replay was,
the network provider is
blocking web sockets traffic.
AUDIENCE: Some of them.
Yeah.
STEVE THAIR: OK.
AUDIENCE: I haven't tested this,
but I've been told that
a web socket can just drop out
on a mobile connection.
I'm going to be listening
to the close events.
But I suppose the question is
simply to ask if that was
anything that anyone else
has come across.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is--
STEVE THAIR: Just repeat
the answer.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the question
was, or the comment is that
sometimes website connections
just drop
out on mobile networks.
And this is a deployment
problem.
So I think there's
two problems.
First of all, web sockets did
go through a very elaborate
process of many revisions
and specifications.
Depending on which server you
use-- so I happen to have
worked on one--
it's the Ruby implementation,
the EM web socket.
If you actually look at the
implementation, we have, like,
15 implementations of
all the drafts.
It's a total nightmare in terms
of negotiating, oh, this
browser supports this
spec, et cetera.
That was problem number one.
So I think we did fail in the
specification process of that
specific standard.
The bigger problem today with
web sockets is you have to
deploy over SSL.
If you're deploying it on
mobile, you have to deploy it
over SSL, because most of the
carriers have some proxies in
between that try to optimize
traffic, whatever that means.
And they look web sockets, and
they're like, look, this
doesn't smell like HTTP.
Close.
Or even better, the blind
proxies, which don't even care
what's in there.
They're just substituting
bytes.
And this is why without SSL,
20% of your connections on
desktop will fail randomly.
You have a proxy that doesn't
understand web
sockets, end of story.
On mobile, it just happens to
be the other way around.
80% of your connections
will fail.
So if you want, you
can reliably
deploy web sockets today.
It's HTTPS.
And that's how anybody on mobile
deploys that at scale.
STEVE THAIR: Great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
with Mozilla again.
Isn't the big reason for library
use that a lot of
browsers still don't support
web sockets, or a lot of
browsers that people use still
don't support web sockets,
which we can't really
get away from?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So we need HTTP
fallbacks for browsers that
don't support it.
Hence the reason for Socket.IO
and all these other
abstractions.
And that's just an unfortunate
reality of not everybody is
able to upgrade to an
evergreen browser.
Some people are just stuck on
an old IE machine that they
can't upgrade.
And I don't know how
to fix that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ILYA GRIGORIK: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE THAIR: Got a question
right there.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
STEVE THAIR: Tell
us your name.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is [INAUDIBLE]
from [INAUDIBLE].
If I use a web socket for
mobile, does it drain the
battery further.
Or as long as it's an idle
connection, it doesn't drain?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes and no.
It depends on how you
use your web socket.
If you're sending periodic
messages every five seconds,
you'll keep your radio
active all the time.
I think what a lot
of people confuse
about is you can have--
so your radio can be
off, but the TCP
connection is still alive.
I think a lot of people
confuse this.
They think the moment my radio
turns off, I've lost my
website connection.
That is not the case.
Your actual TCP connection
is still
maintained by the carrier.
And it's just the radio link
that goes missing.
So I guess the best practice
for web socket traffic on
mobile is, send as few requests
or messages as possible.
Or if you do, just
as with regular
traffic, send it in bursts.
STEVE THAIR: There were quite
a few questions on this list
about radio stuff.
I think Ilya covered it
in his introduction.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hello, yeah,
so I'm Phil.
STEVE THAIR: Hold
on one second.
So there were a few questions
there about battery use and
this kind of stuff.
I think Ilya covered it in his
introduction, that you've got
to be aware of it.
Just one question from me, as
a rule of thumb, do we have
any idea of how quickly
the radios turn off?
Is it once every five seconds,
once every 10 seconds?
If I want to beacon analytic
stuff back,
what's a rule of thumb?
ANDY DAVIES: It's carrier
dependent.
STEVE THAIR: It's carrier
JACKSON GABBARD: [INAUDIBLE].
We got yelled at by some carrier
who was saying that
we-- basically, a time out
from one of our logged in
delivery services was
just underneath
the radio time limit.
We were always just keeping it
awake, over and over again.
You have a lowered [? wait. ?]
The radio [? wait ?] will
stay awake longer than
you think it would.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So its
network configured.
There's a great case study
paper published by AT&T--
STEVE THAIR: Three
minutes left.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Three minutes.
AT&T--
I don't remember
the name of it.
If you just search for AT&T
radio performance, I think
you'll find it.
They have the Pandora
case study.
Pandora app--
you play the song.
They did the right thing.
They downloaded the whole
song up front.
So they streamed the
whole thing.
They turn off the radio.
And then every 60 seconds,
they would send a beacon,
which is just a measurement
beacon.
And they measured it, and they
figured out that those beacons
accounted for 0.2% percent of
the traffic and 40% of the
battery use.
They eliminated that.
They doubled their battery
performance.
AUDIENCE: Just a few points--
I'm Phil Leggetter
from Pusher.
So obviously we use
web sockets.
So I handle most
of our support.
So I just want to back up that
SSL connections when you're
using web sockets, definite.
In terms of the web sockets
dropping, I think that's
because most of the browsers
don't implement ping pong from
the specification.
So we've added that as
our protocol layer.
So we are sending messages
when maybe we
shouldn't have to.
But obviously, there
would be a message
natively from the browser.
So again, if you're using web
sockets in a browser, have a
ping pong time out.
And we haven't had a lot
of problems with that.
We've obviously got HTTP
fallback as well,
because we need it.
AUDIENCE: With regards to a
radio power state, would it be
worth for the developer to
have a means to tell the
browser, here is the request,
and send it only whenever you
have the radio in full power.
If it's an idle state, don't
wake it up just to send this,
because it's not urgent.
This is something I would
like to see, personally.
STEVE THAIR: Military style
microburst, basically.
AUDIENCE: And avoiding excessive
signaling traffic,
which is what happens when
you switch radio states.
It's in the best interest
of everyone not to
clutter mobile networks.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the
answer is yes.
And this is actually something
that we discussed at the W3C
Performance Group meeting that
we had back in November.
There's this new proposal that
we're going to start working
on in, I think, around
May of this year--
it's our timeline--
called the beacon API.
And the idea being that,
it's exactly that.
I want to send a request, like
an analytics request, that I
don't need to dispatch
right now.
Dispatch it any time you want.
In fact, even if you lose
it, maybe it's not
the end of the world.
But just don't wake
up my battery.
So it's almost like the async
keyword on an XHR to say,
sometime, make this happen.
STEVE THAIR: That's basically
the time up
for the network panel.
So I'd like to thank Jackson,
John, Andy, and Ilya.